- And so then I'm like,
"Nobody I know knows I'm here.
No one I know even knows that
I'm friends with this horse."
[laughter]
"So no one's gonna come look
for me."
[dark electronic music]
- [indistinct shouting]
- Huh? Huh? Huh? Huh?
- Come on. Move. Come on.
- What? What's going on?
- Come on.
- This is not happening.
[rapid gunfire]
No, no. What...
I'm--I'm your host.
I'm your host, Roy Wood Jr.
- Come on.
- Ahh, ahh.
- Augh!
- [groans]
[glass shattering]
[panting]
♪ ♪
Mm...ahh!
[bones crunching]
[cheers and applause]
You know her from the show
"Baskets."
Martha Kelly is her name.
[cheers and applause]
My story is about the ups and
downs of friendship,
specifically between me
and a horse that did--
did not belong to me but show
pasture
I climbed into,
because I thought it would
bring us closer together,
and it came close to tearing us
apart, so...
[laughter]
But just--backtrack.
I--the only thing I knew about
horses when I met her
is that I thought that they
liked carrots and apples.
And so I met her because I'd
moved back to Austin
in 2012, and I lived in a part
of the city
that was almost out in the
country.
And there were a few places
that had horses.
And one day when I was walking
my dog,
this horse came to her fence,
and she walked the whole length
of her fence
along with us, and then when we
were on our way back,
she did the same thing in the
other direction.
And she started doing that
every day,
and I never saw any people in
her pasture,
so I thought that she probably
wanted me to go pet her,
because I thought...
[laughter]
I thought I had heard that
horses are like
really big dogs, but...
[laughter]
I honestly believe that when
people say that,
if someone says that, it's
'cause they
were dealing with a big dog
that they thought was a horse.
Because they're not anything
like dogs.
And I--finally, I went to pet
her,
and at first, she would kind of
back away.
And then she finally let me
pet her,
and there were some early signs
that there might be trouble
down the road.
She did a couple times look
like
she was gonna try to bite my
hand,
and then one time when I turned
my back on her,
she grabbed my ponytail and
pulled it really hard.
But I thought that that was,
like,
maybe how horsed play,
and I didn't know--
and I forgot to say I'd started
bringing her
carrots and an apple every day.
I would walk my dog and stop
and give her--
and so I thought that we--
I thought
that's--like,
you could easily by my
friendship
if you brought me a good snack
every day.
So I felt--and she she seemed
to like it.
So--so this is where things
kind of go south,
but it started--it seemed at
first like they were--
we were entering a new phase,
because I found--
I took my dog in for a checkup,
and I found out that
he had a really fast-growing,
untreatable type of cancer
and that he probably only had a
few weeks to live,
and I know that's not a great
topic for a comedy show, but...
[laughter]
But it's relevant to the story.
So that--I was devastated,
because I--
he was my first dog.
I totally treated him like a
person
and loved him like a person.
And I--it's terrible that
someone's laughing
at that part.
[laughter]
That's really--
that's--that's in poor taste.
But--so I'm just saying--
I'm not--but it was
devastating,
and so I got the news,
and I took him for a walk.
And I stopped to her her her
carrots and apple,
and for the first time, she--
after she ate the snacks,
she leaned over the fence and
pressed her forehead
against my head and just stood
there.
And I thought, like, "Wow,
horses are really sensitive.
Like, she could sense that I
was really sad."
That's what I thought.
In retrospect, she might have
been trying to, like,
psyche me out or something.
I don't know.
I don't--I don't know what...
But...so then my dog passed
away,
and then I got another dog,
who's great, but...
[laughter]
That's not part of this story.
But so a little bit later,
I kept visiting her and feeding
her and petting her,
and then I--just one day...
This--this person.
I can't...
[laughter]
So one day I think--
I don't know what was going on
with me,
but probably some, like,
reckless daredevil,
once-in-a-blue-moon thing came
over me,
and I just thought,
"I bet if--like, she's like a
dog.
I bet she would like it if I
was petting her inside
her fence, and...
[laughter]
Because that's what a dog would
want want:
you to stand next to him.
And I should also say,
this had been a couple of
months or more,
and never once did I even just
Google "horses."
[laughter]
It never occurred to me to do
that.
So this day I just decided to--
I climbed the fence and got in
the pasture with her.
I thought I would have, like,
a story tell
my friends later, which I
did,
but it wasn't the kind of story
that...
I thought it was gonna be like
I was really courageous,
but I climbed in with her.
She ran away, and then she came
back.
And then I just walked next to
her petting her
and in a soft voice talking to
her,
and then she kind of moved in
front of me
and turned her back legs to me.
And then I went, "Uh-oh."
[laughter]
"This seems--this is what
horses maybe do
right before they kick
somebody."
So I stepped out of the way,
and then she turned around and
reared back on her hind legs
and started flailing her hooves
at me and whinnying.
And I still wanted to think she
was playing.
[laughter]
But it was kind of terrifying,
so I just started going, "No,
uh-huh, no, ma'am, no."
[laughter]
And then--and then I ran,
and so she chased me behind a
tree,
and--and she wouldn't leave.
Like, she--I thought maybe
she--
once I got behind the tree and
she couldn't get me,
she'd give up, you know,
following,
and then--so at one point I
looked over,
and then her head popped out on
the other side.
And so then I'm standing there
for maybe, like,
15 or 20 minutes.
I'm like, "Nobody I know knows
I'm here.
No one I know even knows that
I'm friends with this horse."
[laughter]
"So no one's gonna come look
for me.
I've never seen any people come
and take care of her."
At one point a car slowed down.
And I--they were looking at me,
and instead of flagging them
down for help,
I thought, "I don't want them
to know that I'm an idiot
who climbed in here," so I just
gave them the wave that's,
"Oh, it's okay.
We're okay over here."
And I found--later I found out
those were the owners.
And--and they--I went like
that,
and they drove away.
Like, they didn't--I don't know
why--
they just saw some weird lady
trapped behind a tree with
their horse,
and, "Oh, she waved.
I guess it's fine.
We'll drive."
So they drove--so finally I saw
this horse go towards the other
part of her pasture.
So I slowly walk out from
behind the tree
and start kind of trying not to
upset her,
walk toward the fence,
and then she came back and
chased me again,
so I ran behind the little
structure
that she had her hay in.
And then that lasted for, like,
another 15 minutes
of having to wait for her to
get bored.
She walked away again.
I ran behind another tree
closer to the fence.
And then the last--
that was the last tree that,
you know,
was the closest to the fence,
and I thought I could make it,
so when she lost interest and
walked away,
I ran for the fence, and in my
mind,
in movies when people take a
run at a fence...
[laughter]
They get--they jump at the last
minute,
so they land high on the fence,
and then they just throw a leg
over, and they're done,
but I ran at the fence,
and I tried to jump, but I
still landed at the bottom.
And then--and then I--
I climbed as fast as I could,
and she was running towards me,
and I threw a leg over, and it
got caught.
My jeans got caught,
so they ripped,
and then I--finally I got to
the other side.
And so at first
I really was mad at her,
and I felt like...
I was like, you know, I'm not--
I'm not gonna come visit her
anymore.
We're--like, this is why I
never see people
in her pastures, 'cause she's
not a nice horse,
and then later I realize I have
to keep going to visit her,
because she's a terrible horse,
and no one else is ever gonna
be friends with her,
so for the rest of the time I
lived there,
I kept bringing her food,
and I wish there was an ending
to this story,
but thank you for listening.
[dark electronic music]
- Martha Kelly.
[cheers and applause]